this week on indiana jones
damn it lovecraft country is back with
an adventure filled episode and there's
a ton to break down
in this video we'll be explaining some
of the episode's biggest wtf moments
including those underground tunnels the
introduction of yahima
and that crazy twist ending but before
we begin make sure to like and subscribe
so you're notified as soon as one of my
lovecraft breakdowns drops
well didn't take long for montrose to
hit the bottle in a recreation of what
is basically my friday night now there
are a bunch of
really cool clues here like how the
radio in the background talks about the
cold war claiming the americans are the
civilized ones in comparison to the
soviets this civilized versus savage
dichotomy is echoed in the museum when
one of the tour guides in the background
talks about
titus braithwick being civilized while
the natives he met were savages the
irony here being that titus was the
biggest savage of them all
the most important thing about this
scene however is that montrose says the
order of ancient dawn's book of law
and precepts which george gave him
before his death a book we saw george
pick up in a mysterious library in artem
in episode 2.
the book depicts a chronological history
of adam eve and
monsters this order is how montrose
atticus and letty are able to decipher
the door
leading to the vault later in the
episode but montrose ends up burning the
book even though in the voice over we
hear
george task montrose with giving that
book to atticus to quote
protect our family instead montrose
burns it even saying it smells like
tulsa which is a reference to the tulsa
race riots which both montrose and
george were a part of
christina arrives at letty's house
telling her that atticus tried to kill
her it seems she's been able to harness
the spell of invulnerability just like
her father
samuel last episode she said members of
the order are lucky if they can
harness one spell in their entire life
but it seems christina has mastered
several making her extremely powerful
but she's really here to retrieve
hiram's orry the mechanical model of a
solar system hippolyta was drawn to last
episode when she tries to get in she's
stopped by a force field now we aren't
sure how this force field came to be
was it some other magical force or was
it the witch doctor's magical protection
from last episode to ward off evil
spirits that's still holding
we even see the blood on the doorway
from that protection spell the ory isn't
here however hippolyta has taken it to
george's shop where she talks to her
father asking
which galaxy can sustain two sons like
this machine has
unfortunately it's broken and she can't
figure out how to get to the gears since
it's locked
a particular note here dee's friend bobo
bobo was emmett till's nickname now if
you don't know who emmett till is make
sure to check out my episode 3 breakdown
it seems his friendship with d
will play a larger role going forward as
episode 8 of this season
is apparently titled jigabobo lety finds
atticus at the colored-only library
researching about all the mysterious
things that have been going on but as
i'll find out his father has basically
taken out all the same books and knows a
heck of a lot more than he's letting on
atticus tells her that he's looking for
clues on titus braithwight's vault which
contains a set of deciphered pages from
the book of names
if he can get those pages maybe he can
start using spells to protect his family
also fun easter egg this little boy here
is reading journey to the center of the
earth which atticus makes reference to
when they later
journey into the center of the earth
type [ __ ] lydian atticus try to convince
montrose to tell them where this
vault is but he doesn't want them to get
themselves killed montrose however does
blurt out an interesting piece of
information here that there are
34 other lodges of the order of ancient
dawn christina plays hide and seek with
a bunch of kids i
found this such an odd thing for her to
be doing but she says she's never played
before perhaps hinting at a sheltered
childhood those of you with a keen eye
will see the
cops who come to pick her up here are
the same racist cops that drove past
letty's home in
episode 3. she's taken to captain
lancaster who we were also introduced to
last episode he says he runs this lodge
of the order in chicago and is curious
why she's come to his territory
unannounced apparently hiram's orary is
the key to unlocking titus braithwight's
time machine
and that's why she's here there's also
this weird moaning man locked away
we're unsure if lancaster just likes to
beat people up and block them away
or if this is some important character
we'll see in future episodes regardless
christina is told to know her place
since she's a woman
and women aren't even allowed in the
order this will likely just
fuel her even more the group is off to
boston on a secret trip to find the
vault disguised as a trip to the
astronomy museum meanwhile rose is off
to apply for a job at marshall's
something she told ledy she wanted to do
in previous episodes but when she gets
there she finds another black woman
already working there essentially making
it impossible for her to land the job
as she tells william later on they'll
never hire more than two black women
back at the museum tree who's on his way
to philly and hitched a ride with the
group
alludes to atticus that montrose is gay
saying that since he left him and sammy
the guy in episode 1 who was caught in
the alleyway with another man
had been getting close if this is true
it would explain a lot more about
montrose's wife hooking up with george
and if i'm going to be honest this seems
to be the only reason why the writers
put tree on this trip
to give that bit of info so it's likely
true
william ends up beating the crap out of
two men tasked with following christina
he tells them he has a date tonight
which we'll find out is with ruby
they hook up and she seems to be totally
cool with the fact he has this satanic
like scar on his chest with ruby pissed
at letty for not telling her about her
mother's secret inheritance which was
actually just money given by christina
this is likely all an elaborate plan to
use ruby
and gain access to the house and the
orrery atticus letty and montrose gain
access to titus braythright's wing at
night
finding a hidden vault underneath the
statue one which leads to a series of
tunnels each path relates to one of
titus's expeditions and i have to be
honest with you i've re-watched this
scene multiple times and i'm still
confused how they knew which path to go
down it has something to do with an
expedition to guyana a renovation to the
museum
but they end up taking the north path
even though guyana would be south of
boston
if you got this part please let me know
in the comments because i was like
ladies first as letty is the first to
traverse the plank over this
giant chasm when it starts to magically
disintegrate they have mere moments to
input the correct order on this vault
door
only to find in the next section they're
racing against time as the tide rises
there's this interesting moment between
atticus and montrose where atticus gets
triggered when he's accused of quote
leaving men behind he says he's never
left a man behind referring to his time
in the korean war but it seems like he
has left a woman behind we haven't
really met gi yet the mysterious korean
he called in episode 1
but expect her to play a bigger role in
episodes to come
atticus also learns that montrose burned
the order's book in an effort to protect
them this is an important note in
figuring out this
episode's twist ending letty finds the
body of one of her neighbors floating in
the tunnel one of the dudes who died by
the ghost
last episode and whose body was left
beneath the winthrop home not only that
but the tunnel links to her home
hundreds of miles away in chicago it
seems these tunnels don't abide by the
rules of space and time heck we just saw
a plank
magically disintegrate this makes me
extremely curious what the other paths
could lead to
other locations or other times after
atticus and mantras have their first
actual father-son heart to heart they
come across a door with a severed arm
it seems as though only those with
titus's bloodline can unlock it and
fortunately for atticus he's got that
covered inside they find titus's
exploration ship and several decaying
bodies
among them holding the deciphered pages
is a two-spirit named yahima one who
possesses the genitalia of both a man
and a woman
she speaks arawak a language of the
indigenous people of south america and
the caribbean
and she tells them that titus imprisoned
her on his ship
and killed her family somehow atticus
understands her language
yahima has the ability to decipher the
book of names something she knows by
having studied the symbols from the cave
of
alamun kundi now i searched aliban kundi
and
nothing came up so it's likely this was
created for the show
however it's uncertain if we'll ever
visit it or if it will be a larger plot
point in the future
montrose takes the pages which causes
the ship to basically
self-destruct and they make their way
back up the elevator to letty's house
taking yahima with them but when she
opens her mouth she lets out
a wailing scream which atticus has to
knock her out just to make it stop
that's because yahima is a siren cursed
by titus so she can't speak
should she ever escape the vault
meanwhile d and hippolyta are on their
way back home after having found out the
group had somehow already made it back
to chicago
she finds dee looking at george's atlas
which was in the glove compartment an
atlas which shows where he was actually
going during the trip
which took his life you'll see here that
devon county is circle the place where
artem is located
and hippolyta turns the car around
likely headed there
in her search for answers atticus tells
montrose that yahima doesn't think she
can break her siren spell but in the
meantime atticus has those pages and
hopes he can figure them out
and they share a poignant moment
montrose even saying
you grew to be a good man in spite of me
this happens mere moments before he
ventures into yahima's room
and slits her throat there has been some
discussion if this is even montrose and
i do think it is
he even says i'm sorry to her before he
does it there's still a semblance of
humanity here but every action montrose
has taken this episode has been for the
protection of his son
so this has got to be one too right we
also know that montrose knows a lot more
than he's leading on
there's something he knows about her and
this whole mystery that we
don't yet something so dangerous he must
kill her in order to protect
everyone just what that is we'll have to
wait and find
out thanks again for watching everyone
please make sure to like and subscribe
and for more bat takes you can always
follow me on twitter at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much